[Music]
hi
i'm madison bailey and this is a glamour
unfiltered special for pride
it has been such a journey working on
outer banks has been
an absolute roller coaster of
family of there's so much newness that
i've experienced
since being on the show like everything
about being
serious regular and being on set that
frequently and
working with people my age was new like
everything about it was just like new
new new and
now we we've kind of like set into our
groove
a little and
it's it's it's been an
unbelievable experience
[Music]
i think i i at one point have thought i
was a lot of things and i've
tried to put i think i realized i was
pan when i was like i'm re-labeling like
all the time like there's probably just
like an
overall thing for this and
it's pansexuality so i
just kind of took that and ran with it
and i was like this makes the most sense
for how i feel and how i feel is i want
to choose somebody based on
a soul connection based on somebody i
really have stuff in common with
somebody i really connect with like
and it didn't really matter any other
details beyond that
i kind of began questioning my sexuality
when i was in high school early high
school years probably
like 15 16. i was
i don't know i was feeling it out i was
feeling it out a little but like
again like i was in carnageville north
carolina i didn't really like have
like this community and if there was the
community it didn't feel like the safest
place to gravitate towards in that town
you know
i feel like people took that tick-tock
as like this is me coming out
and really i didn't put a ton of thought
into it
um tick tock felt like a good way to
like list
list the information of like how i
identify um
but i mean i've been out since i was 18
this is just like
the show came out and then um i felt
like i had to do some type of like
coming out even though it was like
public knowledge to my
friends and my like 2 000 followers i
had before
but then i was like i should probably
tell all these millions of people
how i'm feeling you know
[Music]
my relationship to social media has
totally
changed and i changed my opinion on it
on a daily basis
like whether i decided to post on
instagram that day i'm like whatever
people are going to my instagram to see
who i truly am then like they've
they're already on the wrong on the
wrong path
like they're already you know like go to
my instagram you're gonna find instagram
stuff
for me the whole like queer discovery
was just like within myself
and i was just kind of figure out where
i fit into that
and then i just like immediately had
this platform
and the pressure was on to know like
everything about
everyone else in the entire lgbtq
community
i think my personality disorder affects
what i eat for breakfast
and when i go to sleep it affects
absolutely everything i do
um and i think being pan
and having a personality disorder i have
definitely figured out where i
like fall into all of that because like
my personality is where i basically have
a very broad personality i have a lot of
a lot of identity
crisis um so then i'm i just didn't
know what part of it was my sexuality
and which part of it was me just like
feeling different that day
you know
don't let anybody pressure you to say
you are something or you aren't
something don't let anyone tell you
you're making a rash decision or like
why are you making this decision
now or like just don't really let
anybody interfere with
with how you're feeling is is a
self-discovery
it is a self-exploration that you have
to do by yourself
um just try not to be scared that's so
much easier said than done but just like
try
try to be try to find a lot of comfort
in knowing that like you are on your own
path to live your own life
and you need to make the decisions that
are best for you
to be happy to just like feel like
you're living authentically
you know there are too many people
faking it
i'm gonna just gonna say keilani and i'm
gonna leave her name right there because
something i love about kailani is that
she's very authentic to herself
and you know i feel like with the r b
industry i feel like there is a lot of
pressure
like there's not a lot of queer people
in r b
and i feel like that is a very like like
there's a lot of pressure to sing like
straight romance
songs and i like that she veers off from
that
and she's just like authentic to what
she's doing i like that
[Music]
i don't know if i've had any like
breakthrough moment of like that joy but
like
i just feel the everyday joy of it like
when i'm with my girlfriend like
i felt so much joy when i posted that we
we were together you know like
and the response that i got from that
and
i really i think that really tailored my
my fan base and like it really like
made the people interacting with me on a
daily basis like
an enjoyable group of people
i think i'm at a point right now in my
life
where i need more advice from my younger
self
then than she needed from me you know
but like
if i was face to face with my younger
self i would i would not talk i would
let her
talk i'd be like tell me what i need to
do
to feel that energy to feel that like
i don't care energy you know
for me it's being there for other people
for me it's like
now i get to be this inspiration show
out for a month
my my one year anniversary is during
pride month i'm very
very excited um
but yeah like i i like i have said
because i didn't experience
any of that hardship it really just puts
me in a perfect position to be there for
other people who are going through that
hardship
um so for pride month i want to be like
as loud as i can as like inviting as i
can
i want to feel like
a safe space you know for for other
people and for like
young girls and boys and everyone in
between who
do look up to me you know